kiev's residents are jumpier now the day
after the worst Russian airstrike since
the beginning of the war many are taking
the air raid warnings more seriously
last week most would have ignored the
sirens on Tuesday Morning the Metro was
filled with people taking shelter
I get scared because we
possible Town it is a terrorism your
yet you are not safe at home even if
there are no infrastructural objects
near me two walls and basement will not
save you but what do people in Kiev do
as soon as the all clear is given easy
coffee in the sunshine Anton runs 1900
coffee in central kiev for him opening
as soon as he can is a duty to his
employees his customers and his country
why is this important we are responsible
for those who work for us the business
must keep working our regular guests
keep coming to us even during the last
two days
also we continue to pay taxes and
contribute a part to the country's
budget if we all close it seems to me we
will no longer be able to sign an arms
contract and help our army to liberate
the country
for Ukraine's governments getting back
to normal as quickly as possible is a
vital part of the war effort electricity
must be restored glass cleared and
missile craters filled everything that's
been destroyed will be rebuilt President
zielinski says well look at this
intersection where several people were
killed on Monday the repair work is
already well underway resilience is
Defiance and Defiance ukrainians believe
will win them the war Rory challenge Al
Jazeera Kiev